Apple finally announced the new Mac Pro
that we have been waiting for for years
and with it a surprise Mac Studio so in
this video I will tell you guys every
single difference along with my thoughts
on the Mac Pro and why I think apple is
kind of giving up and why I wish that I
kept my 2019 Mac Pro that I recently
finally just sold now I ordered two Mac
Studios and the Mac Pro which will be
here early next week so make sure you
guys hit that subscribe button if you
guys want to see our Hands-On
comparisons and where they differ along
with the performance of the new M2 Ultra
chip and if it's worth it over the M2
Max now the biggest difference between
these two is the price tag I mean the
difference is insane four grand compared
to seven as a base starting price but
what comes with that well we have the
same form factor as the 2019 Mac Pro
which makes sense because there's a lot
of room for PCI cards and apple spent a
bunch of money developing this beautiful
design but the Mac Studio is so much
smaller and it packs nearly the same
punch because if both of them have the
same exact chip and for Seven Grand you
still get the bend version as you do for
a four and that is terrible gone are the
12 Ram slots on the Mac Pro so now it is
built in meaning you still have a
maximum of 192 gigs just like on the Mac
Studio and as far as your ssds well that
also goes up to eight terabytes which is
a lot but the Mac Studio can also
upgrade to that at that crazy high price
now there is one difference we tore
apart the Mac studio and showed you guys
that you could easily unscrew and
replace the ssds but Apple never sold
those kids whereas with the new Mac Pro
they are selling the upgrade kits for
that and it's pretty easy to do as we
showed you in our Mac Pro teardown now
the price tag is ridiculous 2 800
so they are destroying you with that but
on the flip side because the PCI slots
you can actually add in the 16 terabyte
card for less money and it actually will
go beyond 26 000 megabytes per second
whereas the Mac Pros is gonna get around
seven thousand so it makes no sense
anyways now internally the new Mac Pro
can still connect regular hard drives
because it does have a few SATA ports so
you can buy this caddy from Pegasus and
yes it is compatible with the 2023 model
but it is 400 bucks so you can easily
get an external unit for your Mac Studio
and I love that the Mac Studio has that
super fast SD card slot on the front we
use it all the time and as far as
connectivity the Mac Pro has eight
Thunderbolt ports compared to six on the
Mac Studio so you get two more but I
think for most people that won't really
matter so the biggest difference is
mainly those extra PCI slots and the
good thing is that they are PCI Express
4. the Mac Studio can connect to
external PCI units over Thunderbolt but
because of the bandwidth limitations you
only get about 2 800 megabytes per
second at the peak for data transfers
compared to over 26 000 internally now
that's not a big deal for a lot of
people but if you do need things that
need a lot of bandwidth for example this
card right here will go over 26
000 go up to 64 terabytes in one card
it's very expensive that's just
something that you cannot do or for
another example if you need Network
talking cards that are very fast for
example a hundred gigabit per second
that will work in the Mac Pro and I
think it's gonna be just for crazy
companies that get the server version of
the Mac Pro this could be something that
they might need now for people with the
Mac Studio you could still get external
uh 10 gigabit Ethernet or even 25
gigabit Ethernet but the 25 will still
be throttled in maximum performance
because of Thunderbolt and there are no
Thunderbolt 4 external PCI card units
that I have found yet Apple also
mentioned that the Mac Pro can ingest 24
streams of video at one time with those
PCI Slots of course that's something you
can't do with the Mac Studio but who
needs to do that almost nobody and
personally I think that this Mac Pro
just will not sell well at all maybe
even worse than before if Apple didn't
launch the Mac Studio which is actually
quite a good upgrade especially if you
need raw GPU performance then the Mac
Pro might have made a little bit more
sense or if they price this lower just a
little bit more expensive not a 3 000
difference maybe if they kept it on
unbinned for that base model and maybe
gave you a little bit more SSD in the
base that wouldn't cost them that much
and it'd make a much better value but at
three thousand dollars of a difference I
think that people that buy this thing
say a year and a half two years from now
when we get new chips and they finally
release something that is more powerful
as than the Mac Studio for example we
had many leaks of the extreme chip which
would be four M1 or M2 max style chips
that are put together giving you double
the graphics performance in CPU well
when that comes out whoever buys the Mac
Pro now will be very disappointed and I
mentioned in the beginning of this video
that I'm kind of disappointed that I
sold my Mac Pro it took me a year year
and a half to sell that thing and I had
to drop the price down to a very low
price but personally I think that this
Mac Pro is a disappointment and some
people might still want to go and buy
the Intel version the CPU performance
isn't great but you can put in four
graphics cards in there from AMD and get
killer graphics performance if you're
doing a ton of Graphics rendering and
the ability to have up to 1.5 terabytes
of ram which some people do need for
crazy kind of work well that might
actually raise up the price of the Intel
Mac Pros because apple is no longer
selling them but because the chips are
the same these Mac the Mac Pro and Max
studio launch at the same time
I think that's really going to hurt the
Mac Pro and I think a lot of people are
going to upgrade to the Mac Studio if
they needed to or if they need a little
bit more performance because in some
things like 3D rendering the new M2
Ultra chip which is available in the Mac
Studio is way more powerful than the m
M1 Ultra but we showed off the
bottlenecks with graphic scaling with
the M1 Ultra it looks like apple has
fixed that and now even the M2 Max for
3D rendering beats out the M1 Ultra I
mean that difference is massive and you
can get that in the Mac Studio now the
Mac Pro does come with this 200 keyboard
without Apple charges for it and the 100
Mouse the Max studio does not come in
with that but a lot of people would
rather use their own that are more
ergonomic so I don't think that's a very
big Value Point and I think overall this
is the worst way they could have
launched the Mac Pro if they're not
giving any exclusive performance at all
and they're charging a three thousand
dollar price Gap and they're launching
both of them at the same time it just
sucks it would have been better off not
upgrading the Mac Studio and getting
people to upgrade their Mac Pros but at
this point I just want to hear your guys
opinion what do you think about this I
think it's one of the worst ways to
launch a product that they could have
done and I honestly think that they're
kind of giving up on it they could have
done so much better even the power
supply is still 1280 Watts that haven't
even touched it they don't need that
performance but they're just putting it
in so it's a very expensive component
um so you guys let me know your thoughts
would you rather have a smaller
enclosure with less slots maybe that's
custom designed for a lower price so it
wouldn't cost so much I want to hear
your guys's opinions of course click
that Circle above if you guys want to
see our Hands-On comparisons May
the thermal performance between the two
machines and anything else and M2 Max
for some to ultra click that video there
if you want to check out something else
and I'll see you in the next one
[Music]